calm this morning after another night of
heated demonstrations in Minneapolis and
more than a dozen other cities across
the country the anger is spreading over
the deadly arrest of George Floyd
bail was set at half a million dollars
for fired Minneapolis police officer
Derek Chauvin who was arrested Friday
siobhan is facing third-degree murder
and manslaughter charges in connection
with Floyd's death the other three fired
officers have not yet been charged but
deep in the middle of a pandemic
hundreds of mask-wearing demonstrators
took to the streets of Minneapolis
demanding justice for a fourth night on
the west coast demonstrators blocked
busy roadways in Oakland and Los Angeles
in Oregon officials say police
headquarters in Portland were vandalized
and then set on fire Jeff Pegues has
more from Minneapolis this morning Jeff
good morning good morning every day that
we wake up here in this city we see more
damage rather than less and obviously
that's not what city or state officials
want they want to try to calm things
down and that's why they instituted this
curfew last night at 8:00 p.m. which the
protesters defied but what we're seeing
this morning firefighters hard at work
putting out more flames and smoke down
this street we see at least three to
four fire engines they're trying to
douse the smoke in the flames
just beyond these firefighters here
dragging the hose you can see absolute
rubble so that is obviously a building
that has been totally demolished but
every time they put out one fire
something else pops up down the block
you see a ruptured gas line so they are
extremely busy and this is just one of
many fire situations across South
Minneapolis and firefighters can't do
their job without the help of the
National Guard they are serving a dual
role here not only with crowd control
but also security for firefighters who
as I said have a lot of work to do what
we're hearing this morning is that there
will be reinforcements coming in for the
National Guard and our David Martin at
the Pentagon is reporting that US
military police have also been put on
alert the governor of this
has been trying to call for calm trying
once again to send the message to
demonstrators that they have to do this
peacefully but that has been a difficult
message to get out because once again we
are seeing destruction across this city
Michelle Jaffe you have been on this
around-the-clock we thank you for that
we also are telling you to stay safe as
well